what if you done with social media for
last one that you'll duplicate four laps
to and what we cut out is interests a
waste of time or as a health Fleur I
will advertise on your site oh yeah uh
twitter i'm still getting that you know
art is not as much as me but I've been
trying to be as active as possible and
on social media networks and I wasn't as
much with the first season but with the
first season I had an app for the show
and so that was something but it's still
I know it's like it's a whole job on
itself marketing you really need like a
dedicated person or team to that I can
do my own little thing of like that's
right that's a chance right again all
that stuff so i can try and but it's
also intended on the x pretty ha well I
mean between the two of us you sure you
sure are but I mean this is he it's a
right on the head which is you do need a
full-time team and it's like what we're
saying i think i remember it was on
camera off camera about crowdsourcing is
that it's a sort of a full-time effort
you have to keep trying out that's why
you know I want to try helping any way I
can because I know how tough it is and
it's a huge undertaking an idea but I'm
willing to try and help and that's what
we all need to do this time and I think
there's going to be more of them i'm
going to try something new though yeah
yeah we're all going to take laps to
Hollywood Boulevard and we're doing live
performances and then staged readings
stage we're doing bounce I'm not giving
up keys ok but lovely taking this on the
road we're doing found space theatre
it's fantastic you know I'll wear a fat
suit and a fake beard not just jog
around like although the like the Darth
Vader's and the Bane's not Chinese
Theatre yeah great pictures taken ya
know but um yeah so it is a full group
thing and I think in first time it was
such a small effort literally was you
know two people on a track with a couple
other people flittering in and out and
now it's a bigger world so we want to
make it more of a
we effort like you know Chad could
shoulder the burden of a two-person
family but now it's like a six seven
eight person family it's everyone's got
to pull their weight and so we want to
help well and even though social media
is a huge commitment and sometimes it
almost feels disingenuous like you're
trying to get people to be your friends
so the man valdo your dad oh yeah it's
still necessary i'll call it evil
because that's a lot more but and
sometimes it is but so what do you mean
urdu yeah this is a rippling that's not
fortunate circumstance I just like me
because you know I have something yeah
pretty much like you come and see my
stuff I might see yours not necessarily
promising but definitely come see mines
that's what people tend to do is see
what you mean anybody it's very true but
at the same time it is necessary to
going so do you think you'll spend more
time maybe talking on twitter about
other interests that have nothing to do
with acting and maybe gain people that
way or what do you plan to do because
you will need it for crowdfunding very
true um I guess you just try to get
people on board for who we are it's
really what you try to do is you sell
part of the product that you sell part
of the person who's behind the products
you know it's but as far as like talking
about other things I have been trying to
do that because I don't want it to just
always be about you know hey I finished
the script it's like how interesting is
that okay in pleasure thank you PM is
coming yeah well unfollow you okay I
don't know it's one of those things
where I'm learning as I go and I'm and
I'm i am trying to put more i guess a
little entertaining little tidbits on
the twitter the twitter season second
apply yeah you're picking up my habit of
being like the out of step with
technology guy oh and the Twitter and
the Facebook and the Twitter MySpace no
would you like tumblr I do love tumblr
about tumblr because i love it too and I
feel like a lot of people and the film
industry aren't as geared toward as
artists into it as the art communities
right but i think that that is changing
though i think i think there's a it
feels like there's been seeing more and
more like film productions going on to
tumblr it's a really easy it's a really
easy way to create your own website and
so that's what i found that was great
about it is that i don't want to spend a
lot of time doing code or whatever cuz i
used to use dreamweaver but it's a hell
would program the truck it is a hell of
a program it's it's not a dream it's a
nightmare it's that it's a nightmare
weaver yes and this was just a very easy
way of me to get my stuff out there and
so that's why i gravitated towards if i
don't really think of it as like a
social network thing but i guess it is
well you mean one because it well as far
as the iphone app for it looks a lot
more social network even if you i were
to go on to the tumblr main page on the
internet like on that it's like
highlights and you can follow certain
trends and follow certain well i can't
think of a word subjects oh yeah yeah
hannah settings all that stuff so yeah
i'm doing this stuff
you